مع استمرار تساقط القنابل والصواريخ على
منطقه خرسون تطلب السلطات الاوكرانيه من
جميع المدنيين ترك المدينه في اسرع وقت
ممكن
قتلت القنابل صبيا في السادسه من عمره
فيرسون يجب ان ينشا الاطفال في ظروف
طبيعيه وليس تحت تهديد المدفعيه الروسيه
ولهذا السبب نامر باخلاء الاجباري لجميع
العائلات من المناطق المعرضه لنيران
العدوي المستمره
قامت القوات الاوكرانيه بتحرير مدينه
خرسون في شهر نوفمبر من العام الفائت ما
اجبر الجيش الروسي على الانسحاب جنوب نهر
دنيبرو ومع ذلك تسيطر موسكو على مساحات
واسعه من الاراضي في المنطقه وقد نفذت في
الاسابيع الماضيه العديد من الهجمات
الجويه يقول المسؤولون الاوكرانيون الذين
سجلوا مؤخرا خمسه وسبعين قصفا جويا خلال
يوم واحد ان المدنيين يصارعون من اجل
البقاء في خرصا
كنا في المنزل عندما سمعنا صوتا انفجار
قوي
اصابت قذيفه او قنبله يدويه انابيب الغاز
واشتعلت النيران في كل مكان
اوصت السلطات الاوكرانيه بمغادره المدنيين
منطقه خرسون في شهر اغسطس الفائت لكن
عمليات الاخلاء الان لم تعد اختياريه